she can't do 10 pirouettes you know that
done shut up
[Music]
you might have a bad reputation Abbi but
that's never stopped us from cheering
you on without you dance moms would
never have become what it is today your
comebacks your no-nonsense attitude and
your fiery energy have turned us into
total Dance Moms fans we heard the
audition process isn't an easy one to
get through so tell us Abby what do you
look for in a dancer and don't say
Maddie Ziegler because that ship has
sailed the old and new Dance Moms cast
went through a lot to win their spots on
the show and every single one of them
deserves to be where they are today but
just how far do moms have to go to win
their kids a spot on the show watch
until the end to find out it is a dream
come true
there's no room for good Abby Lee Miller
doesn't pride herself on students being
good enough she prides herself on them
being the best so if she sees any
mediocre dancers auditioning for a spot
on her show she won't hesitate to send
them home
this adds loads of stress to an already
stressful event in many young dancers
lives Dance Moms in the making Abby Lee
Miller might be searching for the next
Maddie Ziegler but the show's producers
are looking for the whole package they
want to tell in a dancer who has a
mother that fits their desired profile
during the audition process the moms can
be seen telling their kids just how
important their auditions are
it's not good today it's great today the
kids look stressed out and nervous but
that's no surprise these one of the
dance moms are turning up the heat on
audition day after all if they're kids
below it they'll miss out on an
opportunity of a lifetime you're
competing against the best before ever
making it into the audition room dancers
need to send in an application form
we'll go over this jaw-dropping
application form at the end of the video
so don't go anywhere since Abby wants to
make sure that she doesn't waste her
time
dozens of dancers are handpicked by
producers before being brought in for
auditions if a dancer gets a callback
and is asked to audition in person they
know that they're competing against the
best dancers throughout America no one
is safe during the audition process for
season 8 Abby Lee Miller mentioned that
she was keeping three girls from season
seven on the team but Abby made it clear
that they weren't when it comes to
audition day nothing is set in stone
a dancer could be given a spot on the
show only to have it taken away when a
better dancer comes along young and
confused there's nothing wrong with
starting young in fact most dancers
start leaving their path to success at a
very young age but some of the dancers
auditioning for Dance Moms season a it
seems a little confused while their
parents knew exactly what was going on
and what would that stake some children
look lost and confused the dark truth
about the audition process is that some
mothers push their kids too hard too
fast the application form before getting
the chance to dance your heart out in
front of Abby Lee Miller and the rest of
the crew dancers need to fill out an
application form the forum is designed
to find out about the dancer their
mother and their family life Abby wants
to know how old the dancer is which
studio he or she dances that and what
their parents do for a living this last
one might sound a little invasive but
Abby wants to make sure that her dancers
parents can support their child should
they make it into the ALDC you have to
sell yourself while it's the kids who
will be competing for a spot on the show
it's their mothers who need to sell them
to the studio
parents are asked how good their kids
are on the application forms and moms
are supposed to rate their kids from ten
to one but in reality the ALDC is
looking for mothers who go the extra
mile and write something like Maddie
Ziegler might be a 10 but mike is an 11
how determined are you if you want to
win a spot on Dance Moms you need to
prove just how dedicated you are the
application form is designed to we now
undead ik ated dancers dancers are asked
to describe just how much dance means to
them Abby wants to make sure that dance
is the most important thing in their
lives or else she's not interested in
casting them the competition Abby Lee
Miller wants to find the diamond in the
rough
she wants a confident classy and
talented dancer to earn a spot on her
team and to find this dancer Abby asks
the kids who their biggest competition
is in the whole wide world to make it
through this question kids are supposed
to answer with dance icons like Jennifer
Lopez Beyonce or Maddie herself the real
deal
but when it comes down to it the
producers of Dance Moms are looking for
drama at every turn and they want to
make sure that moms are going to turn up
the heat so the most surprising question
on the application form is directed at
the mothers they're asked to reveal
which og dance mom they would bump heads
with the most this way the producers can
get a sense of their personality so
there you have it guys the dark truth
behind the dance moms audition process
who's your favorite dancer from season 8
tell us in the comments and thanks for
watching don't forget to give this video
a big thumbs up and be sure to subscribe
to the themes while you're at it we'll
see you next time
[Music]